so when after the wedding happened we
moved in to Barnett's house we didn't
end up staying there but for a couple of
months we actually been an apartment now
at the Braves Stadium it's just more
suited to your lifestyle yeah it's more
suited to our personalities and our
lifestyle right now we have a lot of fun
living there and just going adventuring
time so yeah it's pretty much been
traveling around doing crazy stuff like
going yeah cruise and stuff so yeah the
cameras were a little bit overwhelming
actually at times I was always hiding
from him but anyways I I don't know I
think I think we kind of just got to
live our lives you know we got to see
how we were together without all that
stuff and I think I think we kind of
bonded over like the fact that you know
we got her we kind of were we were kind
of worn out but yeah we had our fun we
got along well together and we realized
you know that part was definitely so
legit and I think once the honeymoon
phase was kind of over and we realized
like we still want to put the effort
into this even when it's getting hard
it's still it's still what we want so we
fought and we fought for each other a
lot yeah definitely yeah I feel like
there's a lot that they didn't show
which showed more of like why
woman so I feel like we could have seen
a little bit more and I was kind of
actually disappointed because in my mind
coming into this we were thinking it was
gonna be something that was gonna be
like our love story on camera awesome
it's gonna be so fun the whole time
because maybe the whole thing I think we
just didn't realize there was any drama
there to be seen in surprise this we
actually we went on vacation the week
before the show came because we kind of
expected it no matter what happens we're
probably gonna know what was gonna
happen and we fought we fought we fought
three o'clock in the morning the night
it came out or the day after it came out
we were fine it was more of the Jessica
stuff really so me sing the stuff about
Jessica in Mexico for the first time I
was not happy but I was equally as
unhappy thinking that Matt didn't tell
me but he made a very good point that
he's so pretty but he's so oblivious
sometimes as apparently most guys are so
come work on that to see her throwing
herself at him in Mexico [ __ ] your
sheisty you're so fake coming to my face
like we were cool you were so fake I
think you were a very distant genuine
person and you know what I hope seeing
this you do grow from it because that is
not what the world needs is women that
go behind people's backs like that you
were engaged to another man that you
were leading on I am a very
straightforward person I say what I mean
and I mean what I say and I don't
generally mince my words so when
somebody behaves in a way towards me
that I feel like is disingenuous
I generally call it out and I was mostly
upset that you know when I saw about
that stuff for the first time when the
show came out like I had an inkling
after the birthday party that she had a
crush on him still so like I made my
stance at the bachelorette party which
was not great but a lot of alcohol
involved or it was a bachelorette party
guys
but I've made my stand there but I think
also seeing what else was going on
behind the scenes that I didn't know
about and her behavior towards me it
bothered me like I don't like when
people are disingenuous Ords me I don't
like fake people that's not what I
surround myself with and I feel like if
you aren't called out what is there if
there's no repercussions what's to stop
you from doing it again you've got to
learn a lesson like I want you to grow
and be a better person but that's not
the person you need to be accept her
apology do you even think about do you
guys think about Jessica no I haven't I
completely forgot it I accept I accept
the intent but if I'm being honest which
is my thing I like right now I don't
particularly care how she feels about it
like it's it's done and over with now so
it's not relevant anymore but I said my
piece and I'm good and I hope she gets
she grows from it like I hope she's a
better person after this and she's
learned a lesson from that because not
everybody is gonna let you just flirt
with her though man I'm gonna just
saying that's not okay people will call
you out
[Music]